okay I don't know how to do this so
we're just going to do this I have
breast cancer I know it's very shocking
it's very surreal it doesn't sound real
but it's real
um I found out about a month ago and
I've had a decent amount of time to
process and and start the process and so
I'm finally ready to share with you I'm
gonna try and get through this as simply
and straightforward as possible I'm
probably gonna get covered in hives
because I'm very nervous and if I look
like I'm smiling over something very
serious it's also probably because I'm
very nervous it's called triple positive
breast cancer and from every doctor or
medical professional or person that has
any knowledge about cancer they have
said it is super treatable it is highly
beatable we are going for cure not
remission here which is
exciting encouraging helpful good and at
this point they think it's stage 2A but
we're not entirely sure just yet so the
treatment plan looks like six rounds of
chemotherapy followed by a surgery
followed by hormonal therapy it's a very
clear treatment plan which is very
helpful for me I even got my port
placement in my arm yesterday which is
basically like a little nanopet looking
device that they embed in the skin under
your arm so that when you start chemo
you can just be hooked up to the machine
like a little Roomba and a charging
station so
cute which obviously made this process
much more real which made me much more
eager to tell you because I do feel like
I have been
existing with a big secret and I just
wanted and felt compelled to let you
know this whole thing has been a lot to
say the least I have been feeling every
feeling all day long
but I am so incredibly thankful to have
an amazing husband and an Incredible
family and friends who have been already
so helpful Elliot and I got married last
fall and I really cashed in on the in
sickness and in health part of our vows
I think way quicker than he expected I'm
not really great at taking care of
myself nor am I good at letting people
in to take care of me in any way or to
help and this really you're confronted
with having to put yourself first and
you need to let people help you so how
did this happen great question
the internet friend and stranger so a
few months ago I had my annual
gynecologist appointment and before that
I had sort of noticed a weird lump in my
left breast but I really had to like
talk myself into bringing it up to her
in the appointment because I thought
that I was just a stupid little girl
that didn't know how girl bodies worked
and it's probably just muscle tissue and
thank God I listened to that little
voice inside of me that finally got the
courage to bring it up to her because
she also thought it was abnormal and
gave me the list of a few surgical
doctors to seek out so get those lumps
checked and do not be afraid to ask a
doctor what you might think is a stupid
question so then I went to a surgical
doctor she ordered me a mammogram and an
ultrasound and she ordered it under stat
which is fast so already had a little so
then I went and I got my first ever
adult mammogram side note uh those
mammogram machines are very silly if you
thought you had some Integrity going
into a breast Imaging facility
you really leave with a lot less so I
got a mammogram and an ultrasound back
to back and the nurse after I got my
ultrasound she left the room to go give
my results to the in-house doctor there
who I never even saw she came back with
another piece of paper that was ordering
me a biopsy again stat at that point
myself and Elliot were
unsettled to say the least but the real
kicker who's when I got the biopsy the
doctor that did it didn't say much to me
she didn't really even introduce herself
but the first thing she did say to me
when the procedure started was five
years ago when I got diagnosed it was in
this exact spot
and I said
oh
cool because Woody I couldn't help but
laugh after I got in the car after I
cried uh about that because that was so
specific but she was also so nice and I
think in hindsight she might have been
trying to like show me look at where I'm
at five years later I'm a doctor doing
your biopsy like not all hope is lost
you're probably also wondering have I
talked to Hank Green yes I have I have
been texting with him and his videos
have been so incredibly helpful and I am
now eagerly awaiting his cancer stand up
to read through which he has promised to
send me because I'm gonna need comedy
through this process comedy jokes
laughing that all really helps me
process very difficult things and not
from a place of denial or deflection
about the reality but rather from a
place of
aiding me through the hard laughing
feels like it helps me breathe within a
situation that I feel like I'm holding
my breath like this is a very serious
situation I know that but there's also
some humor to be found here I mean the
joke's not lost on me that I've spent 15
years not using my boobs to get
attention on the internet and yet here
we are and that I'm announcing this
during cancer season it's all right
there so what's next well this is my job
now I'm going to fight this little
of a thing in my left breast uh as best
and as strongly
and as gracefully as I can pun intended
interesting to me that I feel so
confident in being able to take this on
while feeling the full spectrum of every
other emotion all the time like I've
said I feel like I've been working
really hard the last couple years to try
and get my confidence back a few years
ago I just really felt like I had lost a
sense of myself I was overwhelmed with
burnout and I didn't know who I was if I
wasn't some silly little Persona in a
box doing Shenanigans so I took a step
back from content creation and in the
meantime I got a graduate degree I got
married and this year I started to feel
really like myself again but evolved and
I was really excited about the idea of
starting to make content again from this
healthier more grounded place and then I
got breast cancer so I still have this
desire to potentially make content but I
also need to listen to myself and play
it by ear the first step I think is just
doing this letting you in I believe they
call this vulnerability something I am
not used to doing on the internet but
hey I I said I'm growing up and maybe
this is a sign of it I'm no science
Communicator like Hank is so I won't be
able nor do I have an interest in trying
to communicate the science of all of
this
I am more what you would consider a
silly little Communicator so if I
make content around this it will have
the qualities of perhaps a silly little
so I'm still going to be making
episodes of this might get weird the
podcast that memory Hart and I do every
week as long as I can and we're gonna
work to find ways in which maybe we
pre-record some episodes and I still
want to post and contribute to our
patreon that we have as much as I can
the other immediate thing that you kind
of learn in this process is that you
cannot plan for the future you have to
take it one step at a time and
um this was the next step for me so
that's kind of it for now I have breast
cancer you now know I'm doing okay it
was a hard few weeks after I found out
but I have the most amazing and
supportive husband and family and
friends and I'm doing well and I'm ready
to take this on and I know I can take
this on I just have to take it one step
at a time so thank you for listening
there's no non-awkward way to end a
video like this so I will see you soon
awkward goodbye